let's move on we got a big story to
start off the hour the crisis over the
shortage of baby formula this month the
out-of-stock rate hit an astounding 43
percent leaving many parents scrambling
relief could be in sight after the fda
cleared the way for the nation's leading
supplier to restart production at its
michigan plant still it could take up to
two months for that formula to actually
hit store shelves parents have been
telling us about their desperate search
for supplies in the meantime here's what
we've learned
it's
hard physically
mentally
financially
sometimes i do cry at night it's
definitely stressful knowing that you
know if if we can't do breast milk that
there might not be
an option for her it's like a scavenger
hunt every week we'll literally waste a
whole tank of gas in a day
trying to find formula and maybe only
find one can you show up at the parking
lot you've kind of got this hope and you
turn the corner uh into into the baby
food and formula aisle and it's just
absolutely barren and it you know it
breaks your heart a little bit more
every time it's crazy
it was like the toilet paper in the
sanitizer when everybody was looking for
a toilet paper and sanitizer gone off
the shelves he needs formula
i just don't understand why it's taking
so long when my daughter doesn't drink
the whole bottle i'm like oh my gosh she
just wasted like two three ounces i'm
like that was like a scoop that we could
have saved
[Music]
boy they don't call it liquid gold for
nothing right now american academy
pediatrics spokesperson and pediatrician
dr alana levine joins us now with more
on this i want to talk about what
parents can do if they have no formula
at all but let's talk about the other
situation first which is you go to the
store and the formula that you usually
have is not there so you have to make a
switch how how much can you switch and
what are the risks of doing so right so
we're actually in a crisis situation
right so the advice during a crisis
situation is different than under normal
circumstances so parents really need to
find an fda approved formula
that is appropriate for their child so
if you have a child that doesn't have
food allergies or special health needs
buy the formula that you can find on the
shelves and if that means you have to
switch every couple days
i'm okay with that i think we really
have to balance adequate nutrition with
safety right now if you have a
particular formula that your kids are
really uh stuck uh on uh and you're
running out you can't find replacements
is it okay to dilute the formula in the
short term in the hopes that you'll find
stuff in the medium term i'm gonna give
you a hard no on that it is really
dangerous to dilute formula you
impact the nutrition right so you're
diluting the actual essential nutrition
nutrients that the baby's getting and
that can lead to growth and development
problems in addition to which you're
totally throwing off the electrolyte
imbalance and those electrolytes are
critical and can lead to major health
problems like seizures for example do
you believe that we're even in this
situation yeah i mean as a doctor can
you even believe that in the united
states of america in 2022 you're sitting
here having this conversation it is
unfathomable to me that we are actually
here i i just i never in my 20-plus
years of practice ever thought we'd
arrive here but now were you gonna ask
this about parents making their own
formula because now some parents are
saying you know what i'll just make my
own go online and get a recipe right and
you know we used to do that generations
and generations ago but again i'm going
to caution parents against doing that
why because formula's so complex it's
this delicate balance of nutrients and
minerals the balance between protein and
fat and if you throw that off it could
actually be dangerous to the baby in
addition to which you you risk
contaminating the food sources that
you're giving to your child what about
parents introducing solids a little
sooner than expected if you can't dilute
it make your own we'll just introduce
these solids i think my baby can you
know nibble this down and hold it down
right like my grandson's eating avocado
and tomato and prunes is that good i
love it avocado is one of my favorite
foods so you can start to introduce what
we call solid foods which are really
purees to bake
between four and six months
and
but the thing to note is that when they
first start eating these solid foods
they're only eating a small amount so
the majority of the nutrition that
they're getting is still from formula
and breast milk as your baby gets older
and you approach a year and they're
really taking three balanced meals a day
then that's when the formula milk starts
to become less important but early on we
really need to have a supply formula for
those babies okay so a one year mark is
when you can start waiting that's what
we're doing we got two canisters left of
a formula that we cannot refill and so
we're just accelerating the weaning
process right and i you know i think
that for older babies they're in that
good situation and we're in this crisis
that i talked about before right so you
can offer whole milk as you get closer
to a year in addition to which there are
toddler formulas for older babies
can you give the toddler formula to the
little babies to the infants so i really
would caution against doing it for the
youngest babies um you can do it as you
get older and get closer to a year
which really means that we have to sort
of band together as a society and for
parents of kids that are older
don't you know don't buy too much
formula just buy a 10 14 day supply at a
time and leave it for the most
vulnerable babies who need it as their
only source of nutrition you have a lot
of no's today doctor
but it's but it's really important
information though it is you know i'm
not knocking it out
i think it's important to
to really understand the do's and the
domes and really avoid the don'ts so
that we can keep our babies and that's
why it's such a dire situation because
there's not a lot of avenues that
parents can take if they're in a crisis
just like the value of the
formula on the shelves this information
is just as valuable so we appreciate you
coming this morning dr alana levine
thank you so much